von online oli jou wassermassen zu einem
neuen video heute machen wir jetzt schon
gesehen eine versuche nicht wegzuschauen
challenge ich habe keine reaktion video
hochgeladen muss um momente gegen in den
menschen fast gestorben sind wohl ein
paar von euch und das gemeine reaction
also überhaupt besser aber das video hat
einen echt gut funktioniert die
verbindung ist gut die bewertungen sind
auch voll okay eigentlich die kommentare
auch gut deswegen durch noch war aber
wisst ihr was sollte ich kann verstehen
warum man sich aufregt wenn jemand wie
gemacht ich habe mich mal eingegeben
versuche nicht weg befördert youtube
versuche nicht wegzuschauen ist das
codewort für die [ __ ] ecke von
youtube das trifft mich so sehr eine
wirklich schöne kollektion an
ich laufe einfach wie es an haben wollt
dann gebt einfach versuchen nicht
wegzuschauen dabei auf ein video aber es
gibt leute die machen mit ab und zu gibt
leute die machen nicht an dem kanal ist
hat mich auf jeden fall gut gesichert so
die leute zu sehen die da kommen wenn
man eigentlich versuche nicht wegschauen
wenn ihr auch und wie man sich in
aggressionen ab und wollte es ja auch
machen möchten allen guten geistern ja
etwas bedeutet hat sich nicht wirklich
die leute holen sich erst machen wenn
ich ja hallo
ja ja ich versuche nicht wegzuschauen
pro woche macht dann ist man keinen sinn
aber okay alles klar über der bucht
bekommt also wie gesagt es geht auch
nicht wegzuschauen wenn ihr lust habt
könnt ihr auch zu hause machen und dann
in die kommentare schreiben
wie auch die weggeschaut
[Applaus]
diese sachen hallo einer linde linde
group corp wenn ich sowas schon seine es
gibt so blöden mit nein das ist
vielleicht noch ein zeltlager auflage
auf den bahngleisen sicherheit wird die
therapie von klammern das kann man sich
von ihnen sich heute das problem dabei
wisst ihr was heute vertrag hätte sich
natürliche selektion wir sind einfach
die dummen individuen einer später
ausgestorben
von der leyen online unter wasser ein
online online online
nein ich hatte wirklich gar nichts mehr
für mich ich hasse unter machen und ich
hasse fahrt gehabt hatte
aber ganz so ernst es geht auch volkmar
oder also jetzt verhältnismäßig würde
ich hatte offene gewässer mehr draußen
weiß nicht was unter einem ist
ok ich muss sagen heute massenszene war
mega spannend aber ich habe nicht
weggeschaut
ich war so klar scheint sich alter ab
jetzt kommen
ich bin befürworter die kommentare in
libyen
du bist du wirklich dass wir die sache
auf youtube eine man wenn man irgendwas
scheiße findet kann man nicht sagen dass
man scheiße findet weil es irgendwie nur
schlechte auszeit auf die umwelt haben
könnte ich bin trotzdem schreibt wird
also solche dinge sieht vor dass sehen
ok ich hab' verkackt leute
[Musik]
[Applaus]
also auch okay ja auch gott oh gott nein
das macht man nicht mit im rennen
es gibt so dumm wenn du hast nicht
verkehren rate für schmale reifen und
dann fährst du fast parallel zum schwur
der straßenbahn über die spurensuche was
hast du erwartet ob
[Musik]
alte wie im ganzen sind
[Applaus]
[Musik]
aber wir sind irgendwie spannend
situationsanalyse kleinere action video
mit unserer kommentare einstiegschance
gefallen bin ja hier um ein klapphandy
unten zum video abchecken last auf jeden
fall zu sein